uh good morning everybody and uh you
know welcome today's uh investors expo
you know trading summit with uh four
great speakers including myself you know
i'm always interested in doing these
because you know it's in trading you
know what i'm going to talk about later
today you know trading is a journey it's
not a destination you know as traders we
always want to be improving ourselves
and what i'll be talking about
specifically is strategic order flow
which in my mind is the pathway to
trading success uh before i begin i'll
just go through a little quick
disclaimer you know trading does involve
risk risk capital is money that should
only be uh
used for trading which you can afford to
lose you know don't uh basically go out
there try to
think that you're going to you know all
of a sudden become a millionaire you
know the the the meme that i like to
describe is
um
you know people buy crypto also you know
next thing they're expecting when
they're going to get uh you know the
lamborghini and this is not how it works
in this in
the world
so what you're going to discover today
is actually a couple of things one
you're going to achieve market
understanding through order flow
and two i'm going to try and get you on
the path to trading success you know
trading is
a difficult
journey for a lot of people you know a
lot of people are
always
you know want to become traders and you
know they think that they open an
account they put money in it you know
they spend some money on on the trading
platform that all of a sudden they're
going to be making money no it doesn't
work that way you know it takes some
effort on your part it's going to take
some um learning on your part and you
know really what i want to happen today
is for you to have sort of that light
bulb moment where you're going to see oh
yeah i could
by understanding what's happening in the
market i could become a better trader
and i'm going to show you how to see
market activity that's invisible to most
traders okay so you know it's
combination you know people say oh is
there a holy grail in trading well
there's not necessarily a holy grail in
trading but it's about understanding
what's happening in the market and be
able to discern things that other people
just don't understand why it's happening
okay and that's really
how you're going to become the best
trader that you could possibly could
so this is for you if you are
whoops
you know basically if you're frustrated
with the markets um where it feels like
you can't do anything right right and
you know it's like every time you get
into a trade it just seems to go against
you you know i mean people like to joke
around sometimes i joke around about it
sometimes
like you know every time i i try to dip
my toe into
bitcoin uh i'll buy bitcoin then next
thing i know it drops because you know i
don't really understand that market i'm
sort of buying it on the hype but when
it comes to trading the actual
markets you know the futures markets the
e-mini s ps crude oil the buns the bonds
you know euro currency you know i know
what i'm doing and i've done it for a
very long time so
you know this training is really for
someone that wants to be successful but
to be successful you have to keep
learning
now imagine if you could wave a magic
wand around right
you would
take better trades you could understand
market structure you can know which
market activity matters you know there's
there's so much activity that happens in
the market that
a lot of it you know everyone you hear
the term noise right
there's a lot of noise in the markets
okay what if you were able to understand
to sort of take away that part that's
the noise and focus and concentrate on
the part that really matters right and
that's where order flow is going to help
you as a trader now for those of you
that are new to one of my presentations
again my name is michael altos and you
know why you should listen to me
is
because you know basically i've got
a lot of experience right you know they
say if you want to learn from somebody
you should learn from somebody that's
done it right walk
you know along with them you know have
them show you what works what doesn't
works well i've got over 25 years as an
institutional futures trader
experience trading at jp morgan i spent
eight years at jp morgan i spent three
years at commerce bank i've been
four years at cargill i spent three
years at dean witter and you know i
spent some time at edf man and
this job that i did was as a trader
right i sat on the trading desk banging
out trades all day long you know
watching the
the dome the depth of market there there
wasn't footprint charts when i started i
started on the cme4
you know and basically the only really
type of order flow that we had was
watching the orders come into the pit
listening to the volume of the trading
pit you know was it getting louder was
it getting
softer you know as the market was making
a high
and you know eventually i left the
trading floor when electronic trading
started up and you know i never looked
back i took to the electronic trading
environment
like a fish to water now in 2013
i left
my nice job at jpmorgan
and you know i just needed some time
away from the market time to recharge
and then you know i started writing a
book called trading order flow okay
which was there was no books on on
trading order flow at all
out there and you know i sat down i
started writing this book you know and
at the same time of course i'm trading
for myself but i realized the software
that was out there wasn't
was very basic right so that's why i
developed my own software
to make reading the order flow easier
because you know at the end of the day
order flow is not a trading system okay
what it does is it organizes the data so
that you the trader can make better
trades we could understand where there's
market strength where there's market
weakness
you know where buying's uh being
facilitated or you know trading is being
facilitated
where there's weak highs or weak lows or
you know if there's a strong high or
strong low meaning the market's going to
keep going higher there's just so much
to order flow that you know i thought
hey you know what it'd be nice if i had
some software that could actually help
me see this a lot easier rather than me
sort of trying to discern it you know
sort of i sat down and i coded up you
know a lot of um
rules that would translate into the
software because you know trading
with software you know it's binary right
it's it's
zeros and ones so you know you have to
be very specific on it and you know that
was eye-opening for me but um
since then i've worked with hundreds of
retail traders to improve their trading
you know in the past
when i worked at you know places like jp
morgan everyone was you know a superstar
he's called you know the term that was
used back there was you know high flyers
because
you know everyone was was very good you
didn't you know have to sort of go
through a training program or anything
like that you know everyone was already
successful in their own rights then when
i started working with retail traders i
understood where people were suffering
in their
um
in their trading you know whether it was
from making bad decisions or you know
the psychology of trading or you know
simply reading the marketing correctly
so you know that's why i like to do
these presentations is just just sort of
get it out there so people can
understand what's happening in the
market now like i said you know i
created software it's called the order
flows trader software and this is what
people have been saying about it you
know michael your your order for trading
software is remarkably helpful because i
can clearly see now
what's really happening in the market
like for example who's in control of the
market on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well okay so you know
there's been a lot of great positive
feedback in the market now people say oh
mike you know if you've been such a good
trader you know all those years why are
you teaching this why don't you just
trade for yourself you know i do but you
know
in life it's about giving back right
what good is the information if you're
not willing to share it you know i'm a
big believer in each one teach one pass
the information on because
at the end of the day what good is
knowing all this information about
trading if i'm hoarding it right the way
i look at it is
there's enough food for everyone right i
want everyone to eat and if you can't
get your own food right now you can eat
off my plate you know there's
misconception that that people have that
that's like oh you know i have i know
how to trade but i can't tell you you
know how i trade because
you might take away my edge well you
know
there's so many different ways of
trading the market and being successful
in the market
that there's room for everybody up there
at the top right it's not like one
person goes up into
you know the the level of profitability
and that means someone gets knocked down
no it doesn't work that way there's
plenty of space for everybody up there
and that's why i like to you know come
on investors expo
is to share this information with other
traders now
what you're going to discover today get
on the path to trading success right
which is
really you know what we all want to do
right we all want to be successful
traders
you know i want you to achieve market
understanding through order flow
and i want you to see market activity
that's invisible to most traders you
know teach you how to see that okay so
achieving market understanding through
order flow now
understanding order flow will make you
understand market conditions now once
you understand market conditions that's
going to keep you on the right side of
the market
and being on the right side of the
market will improve your trading results
all right so this is an order flow
footprint chart
okay and you know at first it looks
daunting to people there's a lot of
numbers up there oh my gosh you know i
don't know what to do with this this is
so
this is too confusing you know the
people just sort of write it off
right away you know i i know
you know my kids are like this you know
sometimes i show them something and it
looks confusing they don't want to
attempt to understand it you know and
i try to teach them you know try to
understand it first because it's to make
your life easier and in order flow right
there's so much information you're going
to see on a chart you're going to see
the volume that's traded on the bid the
volume that's traded on the offer you're
going to see the point in a bar that has
the most volume that's called the point
of control
you're going to see what the difference
is between the aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers in a bar
and that's called the delta now why is
that important is because you know even
though there's volume on the bid side
there's volume on the offer side for a
trade to occur someone has to cross the
bid offer line someone has to go from
working a bid to lifting the offer for a
trade to happen or someone working an
offer has to sell into the bid for a
trade to happen and
that's
not something that a lot of people
really understand for every trade
there's an aggressor okay somebody that
actually went and said you know what i
want to buy this or i want to sell this
right now at the market price
now there's
bids and offers always working in the
market that's in the limit order book
which provides liquidity in the market
but
that can be manipulated right bids and
offers can be entered could be pulled
and not trade whereas when there's
actual trading occurs that's really what
you want to focus on and that's really
the core of the order flow you know
back in the old days you know
the old day 100 years ago right when you
know one of the greatest books on
trading reminiscence of a stock operator
about jesse livermore he was a tape
reader right we've all seen those old
pictures from the 1920s
you know where the the the traders are
sitting around the stock brokers office
and there's like that vacuum tube with
the ticker tape right and people would
be looking at the trades well they
weren't looking at the
limit order book in there they're
looking at the actual trades that happen
right because that's really what matters
that's the commitment of a trader to the
markets right now
so you have delta you have point of
control right delta is the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in the market point of control
is simply the price level in the bar
with the most volume then you have
imbalances right markets trade in a
two-way auction
you have a bid
you have an offer
so if there's more that's trading on the
offer by a certain ratio versus what
traded on the bid that would be called
an imbalance a buying imbalance a
selling a balance would be the opposite
when you have more transactions
happening on the bid side versus the
offer side why
is because it's showing
which side is more aggressive and
there's a ratio that most people use
which is four to one you don't have to
use four to one i know a lot of people
that use three to one could actually use
like two and a half to one i know some
people that like to use ten to one um
it's sort of the industry standard and a
good starting point for most traders is
four to one right and you can see those
are going to be the numbers in a bar
that's blue right so
you can see here three against 56
44 against 178 these are imbalances
greater than four to one
binding balances now sign of balances
are the opposite right so you have two
against 15
30 against 153 these are selling
imbalances so you have more aggressive
selling at this price in the two-way
auction
versus buying at the other price in the
two-way auction
and that's important to know because
that's going to help you keep on
the right side of the market
most of the time because
really
what you want to do is you want to be
trading on the side
of the flow of money and if the flow of
money that's coming into the market is
strong to the sell side why would you
want to be buying if all the the orders
that are coming into the market are sell
order sell sell sell
if you're trying to buy you know you're
getting into a new position trying to
buy well don't you know you'd be
fighting
that stream of sell orders and you know
ultimately you're just going to get
stopped out
now
order flow differs from
the normal bar chart right this is the
normal bar chart okay candlestick chart
and you know a lot of people say well
you know the candlestick charts got so
much information you know what
information all it's got is the open the
high the low the close
right i mean it's colorful which is nice
it's easy on the eyes as opposed to a
normal bar chart but all it's just
showing you where price was you don't
know where
the heavy volume was in a bar and
depending on sometimes where
the volume appears
it could be very indicative of
what's going to happen next in the
market so you know imagine if
you have
you know at the top of this bar heavy
selling then down here you got heavy
buying and the market came back up and
then when it comes back up that heavy
selling that was here earlier is no
longer there you know that it's a green
light to just go higher that's where
order flow is going to help you right
it's going to help you understand the
market conditions now
you know
traders are accustomed to just using
indicators there's nothing wrong with
indicators i create indicators but the
indicators i create are based off of
market internals what's actually being
traded in the market as opposed to the
price and by say what i mean by what's
actually trading i mean
um you know the volume the trade on the
bid the volume that's traded on the
offer whether it's buying and balances
selling and balances where the buying
occurred in a bar where the buying or
selling occurred
in context of the market structure now
if you're just looking at a normal bar
chart you're not getting any of that
information right you just seen where
the open
high the low the close was in the barn
whether the bar opened
and closed higher where the bar opened
and closed lower and you know it it
what traders like to do is they like to
try and simplify things okay that's why
they create indicators and the problem
with price-based indicators
is one you're treating all prices the
same and not all prices that trade are
should be treated the same because at
some prices you could have heavier
volume some prices you could have very
very light volume and other prices is
probably just going to be your normal
volume you know a lot of people say oh
you know i got chopped up today in the
markets or the markets you know there's
a lot of noise in the markets well when
you're just using an indicator based on
simple price
analysis
basically you're making an indicator
based on noise if if you're saying you
know most of what happens in the market
is noise and you're just putting an
indicator on noise but if you're putting
an indicator based on
what's actually being traded in terms of
volume in terms of
the two-way auction in terms of balance
you know in terms of imbalance in terms
of aggressive buying or
aggressive selling of passive buying and
passive selling you know you're really
going to understand the market
conditions a lot more because remember
you should be trading market conditions
not price
right people say well price is the most
important thing because you know that
that's what gets people to buy or to
sell
well prices really you know something
that people are going to make their
decision on but
what you should be doing is
you know is the market moving higher or
moving lower now it's one thing to look
at pricing yeah price goes you know
price sticks higher markets going higher
just buy it you know mark market ticks
down to sell it well
you know it doesn't go that direction
forever you know you can see that
there's times where the market just sort
of goes sideways
goes up then just goes sideways goes up
then finally sells off what as a trader
you know what you want to know is you
know all this stuff here you know it's
probably noise all this stuff here is
probably noise but if you get to a point
where it's like okay maybe all this
buying is done and once the buying is
done and you're up at the high of the
day this is yesterday
the market is right for a sell-off
right i mean we hit a high earlier here
market just went sideways made a new
high market went sideways he made a new
high but then the market sold off and as
a trader you want to be looking for
those clues
as to
why the market is selling off and
position yourself to be
short in that in this case right because
you're watching the market condition
you're not necessarily watching price
because you know you just made a new
high okay i should be buying just made a
new high okay great i should be buying
you made a new hire yeah sure buy some
more but if you were to buy up here
next thing you know the market dropped
you know 10 points
almost 20 points within you know five
ten minutes right you're going to get
loss after loss after loss if you think
that way i mean you might have some
small wins but your losses are going to
be
very very big
now
again being on the right side of the
market is about
being long when the market goes up short
when the market goes down and more
importantly
out of the market when the market isn't
doing much of anything really you know
what you want to do is you want to
be able to understand right people say
oh you got to be in sync with the market
yeah you do there's a lot of times where
the market isn't doing much of anything
it's just basically rotating around
going sideways okay fine just leave it
at that right let the market
facilitate trade that's what the markets
do but if there's a clear sign that the
market is getting ready to sell off
that's when you get short
right if the market is going higher
that's when you want to be long but
not just because oh you know we made a
new high now i'm going to try and buy a
breakout because you know the market can
go higher but
to where right we don't know where it's
going to go higher if you're just
indiscriminately buying breakouts but if
you're at the high of the day
and everything all of a sudden turns
bearish what you're seeing in here
all right you can see you got selling
imbalances or sorry you've got negative
delta in here getting stronger minus 300
minus 600 minus 685 you know that's a
sign that's telling you you know what
this market
is right for a sell-off right you're
getting lower point of control lower
point of control lower point of control
you have volume migrating lower right
which is telling you that as volume
migrates lower
value is most likely migrating lower
because you know the fair price which is
what value is the fair price of each bar
is going down right that's a bearish
sign now imagine it what it is basically
like you know if you've ever run a
business and you know you know you're
selling
you know pens or whatever and you know
the average price of a pen
is you know two dollars and you're doing
good business good business then all of
a sudden business starts getting slow
you know you got to start lowering your
price right and that's really you know
if i were to
rename the point of control something
else i'll just call it the price tag
right i know the price tag of of the
market at this time is 46.96 now i know
it in this time it's 46.92 now it's you
know 46 91 and a half so i know prices
going down right i know that there's
supply in the market you know that you
know people are happy to try and lower
their price to sell it
right just as if the market was going up
people you know you're going to see
point of controls generally go higher
higher higher higher higher you know
higher higher higher until it stops and
starts coming down
so that's you know be on the right side
of the market okay so
that's all well and good but you know
what how can i tell that in the order
flow well you want to see market
activity
that's invisible to other traders right
because
basically
if
basically order is information okay and
information is valuable to the trader
right we all you know the the big you
know we hear the government numbers that
come out every day almost you know cpi
ppi gdp employment numbers that's
information
right and
information is so valuable you know
people go to jail over it right but
that's called insider information order
flow is not insider information order
flow
basically allows you to see what's
happening
in the market right
the actual trading that's going on in
the market this information that's
currently available to you
you know if you have a real-time data
feed you know from your broker whether
it's like cqg continuum is the most
common one
this information is available for you
you just have to
have a tool that is going to help you
analyze it so for example this is the
e-minis
okay
if you're just sitting here watching the
market right markets just sort of came
down just go to going sideways and then
it rallied right it rallied about 15
points in
you know in about 10 minutes right those
are the moves that as a trader
you want to take
but the problem is often times by the
time people realize that this market is
going up they've already missed half the
move
but if you're
watching the order flow you can sort of
see what's happening right and this box
here where the market is just going
sideways on that's just sideways
activity right that's the the noise that
everyone talks about it's not until you
have this bar here that's very
actionable right we sort of come down
test the lows
rally up
come up and close on the highs all right
people say well yeah that's so that's so
obvious well then by the time they
realize that they're getting long up
here and they just got such a small
trade but if you're watching this bar
form you're already getting signs in
here
that the buying is getting stronger
right not only that but if you sort of
walk it back a little bit you can see
here right you had some very strong
selling come down here minus 1035.
then you go inside
one minus 122 still inside of this bar
here
uh plus 238
and then minus 369 put minus 94 plus 37
plus 86 then boom plus 530. so you're
sort of just hanging inside of this big
strong
selling bar right minus a thousand in
the delta just going inside inside
inside
but delta is
the selling is gone right this was it
this is the big push down this is it
we're going lower everyone's coming in
selling it everyone came in had negative
delta of a thousand
but then no follow through in one two
three four five six bars and not only
that you know the only big negative
delta minus 369
couldn't even move the market lower
all right so then the delta's getting
small in here it's just you know small
deltas minus 94 plus 37 plus 86 then
boom plus 530 but what else do you have
right so you got delta getting stronger
positive so you know aggressive buyers
are
here
you have you know three positive deltas
but you've got selling imbalances in
here this is a green candle right you
got one two three selling imbalances
then you got buying and balances
after you you're closing you're going up
so
it's telling you
that you have aggressive selling in here
but it's being absorbed by
passive buyers right people are happy to
sit here and bid the market right
yeah sure you know we just sold off but
now you're seeing signs of
strong
bidding happening in the market actually
there were signs here earlier in this
bar here at 917 had negative delta of
369 but as a green bar so it's telling
you is
you got negative delta on this green
candle
is because you have
strong passive buying in here you know
you've got the 264 you got the 492.
now these are not imbalances in the 2a
auction but
this is what's causing that negative
delta when you have negative delta in a
bar that turns green generally that's a
sign of absorption because what is
happening is you have aggressive sellers
selling into the bid but you have a
strong buyer there absorbing all that
selling so this was the first sign
and then you're seeing the little little
signs of life coming in here with the
positive deltas 37 86 but then this bar
is more obvious you do have the
imbalances that's 66 against 379
the 33 against 167 right then the market
shot back up and by the time it got
towards the upper end of this bar people
that were selling down here now become
the buyers up here right buying it
because they realize you know we're not
going lower we're going higher so that
tells you now is the time to be getting
in so you'll be getting in around 32 and
the market just shot up to 42 it then
one two three four five six six minutes
and that's the six six bars right there
so that's how order flow is going to get
you into a trade as soon as possible you
know you got a moving average it sort of
comes down here slopes down and it's
coming in here maybe around 36. people
say well we just broke the moving
average to the upside they get long at
36 they ride it up to 42. thinking it's
going to go up and it just comes right
back down and then they they get stopped
out
now seeing what other traders can't see
now here's the market this is e-mini's
again mark is rallying up rallying up
quite strong rally
all right that's what you like to see
you know point of control is mostly
going higher but as you're going up you
get up to this point
where you got strong delta 486 346 but
then 64.
hmm you know you'd be wondering
well
we're going up but what's happening the
aggressive buying is is getting weaker
that's not a good sign of a market
that's going to go up and up and up
all right if you
if you expect this market to keep going
up you want to see delta
you know being steady or growing in a
positive sense not
negative sense you know
going down 486 346 and 64. then you got
negative delta
negative 108 you know it's like okay we
just made a new high now we're looking
at basically negative delta and the
preceding bars the aggressive buying is
getting weaker well what's that telling
you is telling you that you know what
this move is probably over
right and then again you know you're
looking at another 10-point drop in in
basically five minutes now you're also
seeing selling imbalances here on the
way back down you know 50 against zero
nobody traded no one is interested in
working an offer up in here
or rather buying this offer up in here
instead everyone is just looking for the
exit door get me out get me out you know
sell 50 87 65
101 192. you know even in here people i
just you know get me out you know
working off i don't care you know this
is their limit offer right there market
comes back up trades back up to that
point where there was that first
imbalance and then again same thing
more selling imbalances more selling and
balances and the market dropped from you
know 34 you know right down to 24.
pretty much
not say straight line but
you know a nice 45 degree line down
you know but you could see the signs
what's happening
in the delta
rather than delta getting stronger it's
getting weaker as the market is making
its new high
or swing high in this case
right so imagine you're going up you're
making a swing high but the buying is
getting weaker what do you think is
going to happen well fire buying is
getting weaker as you're going into a
swing high
there's not much buying power left and
once that buying power is removed from
the market
what's left is is for the market to
go back down
so
you can see here right this is
uh monday in the e-minis right we had
this low here 46
62 and three-quarters just sort of
hanging around a little hitting it
hitting it bounce uh you know made a new
low by a tick made another new low by a
tick before well it finally started
rallying
okay here you sort of had a little heart
half-hearted rally came back down tested
that low and then shot back up now
this is
a lot of information in here
okay so you know imagine right sort of
follow up on what i just said you're
coming into the low you're seeing the
negative deltas which is what you expect
to see
coming into lows right you expect to see
selling right then over here you get a
bit of buying all right positive delta
800 that's that's a good bullish sign
then here you get positive delta of just
28 then negative delta it comes back
down test the low and then it shoots up
right doesn't look back at all like it
did earlier
so what's the difference
of what happened in here versus what
happened in here well there's a number
of things
okay so first you had you know your nice
positive delta here you within a tick
off the low here at 62 and a half sort
of just sort of went sideways sideways
shot up and you got your higher point of
controls
you know you got your green candles
this bar here you got some negative
delta minus 46 and positive 800 and then
just 28. a market's not going to really
rally very much on a very small positive
delta especially if it's trying to come
up off the low of the day you know if
it's coming up off the low of the day
think of it like um
you know blowing a balloon right you
want the balloon to rise
well you got to put
you know strong
blows into the balloon right strong
you know into the balloon otherwise if
you just do a small one it's not going
to inflate very much right and that's
sort of what this 28 is right it's kind
of a neutral delta in the sense right
what you want to see you know 806 that's
good that's very good nothing wrong with
that you know here you're seeing
54 then 448 200 you know then you got a
little
you know the inhale part you know you
gotta take another breath and 60 okay
that's not the strongest you know then
400 100 right but more importantly now
you're starting to see you know
imbalances as well are you getting the
higher point of controls this these
three bars these three green bars very
similar to these three green bars right
a higher point of control in these three
one two three you've got some buying
imbalances binding balances this one's
got four binding balances this one's
only got two this one's got two
but the delta is stronger right it it
doesn't look like much but it's a shade
stronger 448 and 222 sort of your
this bar is sort of like the push like
okay yeah let's just sort of pile in and
let's go get it higher you know they
couldn't get it higher and it just there
was no nobody else buying at this time
that was really willing to take it
higher you know you have these
imbalances the 315 against 26 the 54
against 10
but what happened
is basically someone just came in and
said you know not on my watch and
started selling these bids here the 54
the 315
the 286 and pushed it back down once
that seller was done then
you know very similar the other thing
that you have here is what's called the
divergence that's this little green
arrow right you have positive delta on a
new low which is a bullish sign right
anytime you have delta divergence right
a positive delta at a new or equal low
or negative delta at a new equal high
that's what's called divergence but you
also have in here something in the order
flow called an order flow ratio which is
telling you basically there's some
stopping volume coming in down here at
the low
all right which is also bullish so
you didn't have any of that earlier
you know the divergence you didn't have
you know the stopping volume didn't come
until now
and now that the delta is a bit more
consistent the point of controls are a
bit more con sorry the point controls
are going higher and you have the
imbalances so there's a little bit more
for you to work with
buying this low you know buying this in
here okay you can i don't think you
would have been stopped out because you
wouldn't have been stopped out until the
market made a new low
you were just taking
quite a bit of heat before the market
went up and and started going in your
favor
but
these three bars is very similar to
these three bars but these three bars
has a little bit more to it right with
the ratio with the divergence now
this is something that i've been
teaching for
since i started releasing my software as
the ratio and divergence trade
which is
you know great trades because
sometimes the market can go from the low
all the way up to new highs or from the
highs down to the lows and continue
making new lows
so this is you know one of my bread and
butter trays the ratio and divergence
now
you know another reason you want to use
order flows keep you out of that chop
right remember what i said you know a
lot of traders complain about oh the
market's so choppy i can't do anything
um that's where order flow is going to
help you if you're seeing a lot of small
deltas
yeah basically that's telling you trade
is being facilitated you know the
aggressive buyers and the aggressive
sellers are pretty equal you know
they're happy to facilitate trade at
these prices you know you're seeing
point of controls sort of
not really going anywhere you know maybe
one or two
up one or two down you know sideways
more or less you know more or less
aligned you know you're getting bars
with point of controls at the same
levels or you know within a tick of each
other these are all signs of sideways
markets
okay which is you know those are the
markets you want to stay out of
you know again something similar
it's about seeing things other traders
don't see and it doesn't have to be as
complicated as i just showed you you
could focus on one thing in the order
flow right this is crude oil yesterday
right we had this nice jump from 6970
all the way up into you know above 70
bucks
well what's the sign just as over here
you know we're training 69.90
and we sold all the way down to 69.60
before rallying again you know say mike
what's the easiest thing get me started
well concentrate on imbalances look for
the bars that have
multiple buying imbalances or multiple
selling imbalances right because that's
where the money flows coming into the
market
right that's you know what you want to
be trading as you know following as a
trader is where the money is coming into
the market
because if if you're looking at this
this chart right here right you can see
these three bars here
this bar here has got one two three
buying imbalances one two three selling
imbalances right that's going to keep
you on the right side of the market
being
where the imbalance is positioning
yourself with the flow of money is going
to help you
um whereas this is yesterday you know
would you be selling here
up here at the at the top you know we
just made new highs
remember right the fed announcement came
out and basically he said uh
stocks to the moon um i'm going to keep
printing money so you know markets you
know reacted as you would expect right
markets lifting all these heavy offers
2000 here 1200 here 1300 here 2000 here
but then it just goes sideways in here
and then all of a sudden now you're up
here at the highs of the day right at
this time
again you know we did make higher highs
later um
but at this point you know people are
realizing you know this market's
overextended itself
right then it came in big selling here
right a couple ticks off the high you've
got very strong negative delta okay
maybe you know maybe people taking some
profits you just had that big run up
and then just so it goes sideways
sideways and then again we're still up
here near the high and then you're
seeing the selling coming over one two
three bars you're seeing multiple
selling and balances two bar
two selling the balances here three here
three here lower point of controls one
two three four okay maybe this move up
is over for now right and you get short
you know somewhere around the 40-ish
area
you know it trades immediately down over
the next couple bars to 30.
so you know that's how you're gonna be
able to see things that other traders if
other traders are just looking at a bar
chart they're not seeing this
interaction
between buyers and sellers out there
right they're just seeing
you know oh the pro the bar closed up
the bar closed down
okay that's it
so
i want you to get on the path to
training success well how do you get on
the path is basically never stop
learning right you'll never know as much
as you should know in training that's
just the way it is okay
so again you know never stop learning
you know anytime the market is at a high
you want to be understanding should i
get short here is it possible for me to
get short here and by reading the order
flow you can see you could put two and
two together now you say okay well i
just made this new high
but just earlier you know i made that
new high we popped up you know should i
be buying this breakout or not well
earlier we're sitting here you see all
negative deltas in here
all negative right then it sort of pops
up here you got some
small deltas 2
14 but then two again then big selling
comes in in this bar minus 56 obviously
you got the imbalances
you know that's not a good sign when
you're at the high of the day to see
aggressive selling come in to see um
negative delta and you know you could
have got a quick
you know what is that 15 20 ticks over
the next couple of minutes
right just as if your
um you know market is going sideways you
want to be looking for something that's
actionable something they say i could
wrap my head around and take this trade
right market is sort of coming down in
and then it just takes off
all right well what's the signs okay so
you're coming down in here you got
negative deltas okay market's selling
off i got some selling imbalances then
you just sort of got these three bars in
here positive delta positive delta
positive delta
all of a sudden you see one two three
buying imbalances
okay you're not seeing sound imbalances
anymore you're seeing the aggressive
buying come in that's your cue get long
all right remember trade smarter not
harder
all right make your life easier use the
power computers to help you make sense
of what's happening in the order flow
this is a chart i've shown you earlier
about the imbalances what if you had
software that's going to say hey show me
the bars that have multiple buying
balances well or selling imbalances so
here you go you have a swing high
multiple selling of balances just off a
swing low multiple buying imbalances
doesn't get much easier than that
right if that's one thing you take away
take away that
now remember trading is journey
not a destination there's always curves
in the road so prepare yourself the best
you can so what you need to get started
never stop learning
learn from a professional and get the
proper software to make market analysis
easier so so far you discover how order
flow puts you on the path to training
success in a field that many people fail
in
you can achieve market understanding
through order flow which allows you to
trade with more confidence and
conviction and how to see market
activity that's invisible to most
traders that you can capitalize on
because you have information very very
few traders
have access to
so i hope you get this one thing when
you understand what's happening in the
market you put yourself in a position to
become a better trader order flow gives
you an edge by presenting what's
happening in the market in an easy to
understand format so how do you make
this happen well you got two choices you
know you could
do trial and error over a year and come
back and listen to another
presentation of mine or you can get
results quickly so what i've got for you
is the order flows trader software now
this is not for everybody right it's not
for people that are looking for a red
light green light trading system you
know or people that think they know
everything or people that don't want to
put in any effort right what you're
going to receive is the order flows
trader software
which is the volume footprint chart with
17 pre-programmed order flow indicators
you get started in minutes it's very
easy to use it works on ninjatrader 8
and i sell this on my website for 8.99
now you're going to also get access to
weekly live training right which i show
you real orderful examples live training
on ways to use order flow and get your
questions answered this is included
right normally people charge 200 300 a
month for access to this you know over a
course of a year that's about two and a
half thousand dollars but you're going
to get that for free but i got extra
bonuses for you right i'm going to give
you my order flow trading course
which is valued at 297 right i sell it
for 297 on my website every day i'm
going to also give you access to the
order flows inner circle video series
which is on my website for sale at 497.
so the software 8.99 the group training
you know per year's two and a half
thousand dollars
the trading courses 297 497 that's over
four thousand dollars you're not going
to pay that today
but what you're going to do is you go to
orderflows.com off three there's no
monthly payments it's only 7.49
right that's all you got to do and as a
special bonus i got a
special bonus for investors expo uh
traders is going to get access to the
order flow playbook which is
a course i did which you know learn how
to use order flow to trade around market
structure
learn how to use order flow to see
market strength and weakness and learn
order flow trade setups i sell this for
297.
so with all that in there you're going
to get all that stuff for just 749. it's
a one-time payment there's no monthly
payments right i hate that stuff monthly
payments because you know sometimes
you'll
you forget to pay your credit card bill
then it doesn't go through then it's
like oh you know you get headaches right
now
i told you earlier i wrote a book on
order flow trading if you're interested
in my book you just go to
orderflows.com
book
and just enter your name and email and
that will take you to the download page
on how to get it after you enter your
name and email
now
i do realize you know we're getting
short on time so to get started
what you have to do is
again just go to
orderflowstrader.com3.html
the link is in the chat below
i think anna's put it in there
so again you know thanks everybody for
taking the time out of your day uh anna
i'll throw it back to you so
thanks for having me and let's put the
link back up there on the screen so
everyone feel interested to get started
go to orderflows.com3.html
and i hope to see you guys on the inside
so thanks anna thanks for having me
today
you're welcome